malheureusement le marché de la
vaccination n'échappe pas aux règles du
capitalisme
on sait par exemple que les brevets ne
sont toujours pas libérés malgré les
appels répétés en ce sens l'autre
facette de ce business
ce sont les contrats et leurs clauses
alors quand les vaccins astrazeneca
tarder à arriver
la commission européenne n'hésite pas à
lancer une action en justice
motif invoqué le non respect du contrat
c'est vrai que le laboratoire suède au
britannique est loin des objectifs fixés
initialement les doses reçues étant
nettement inférieure à celle commandée
les en lançant cette procédure
judiciaire la commission européenne sans
le dire met un terme à la collaboration
avec le laboratoire il est peu probable
que le vaccin astrazeneca soit à nouveau
commandé par bruxelles d'autant que
certains pays comme le danemark par
exemple ont de toute façon déjà décidé
de s'en passer
une situation qui fait les affaires de
pfizer bio ventech déjà plébiscité le
vaccin du laboratoire américano allemand
devrait connaître une activité
croissante en plus des quelques 500
millions de doses commandées
bruxelles prévoit un nouvel accord
encore plus important en ligne ou
contactez nous travaillons avec boeing
pfizer sur un nouveau contrat sur
contrat prévoit la livraison de 1,8
milliard de doses pour les amis et 2021
à 2023
et nous le conclure dans les prochains
jours il garantira les doses nécessaires
pour administrer d injection de rappel
réunion d'athens d'actifs sal au virus
togaf boost chasse hunting and stripes
un investissement à long terme qui place
meiser biotech dans une situation de
quasi monopole sur le continent européen
un partenariat commercial assez opaque
mais des clauses du contrat ont été
révélées par nos confrères de tf1
et si on savait que les laboratoires
avaient négocié une exemption de
responsabilité juridique en cas de
problème les détails du contrat révèle
même que c'est aux états membres que
reviendrait le coût d'éventuelles
démarches judiciaires
chaque état membre participant devra
indemniser et dégager de toute
responsabilité
le laboratoire ses filiales sous
traitants partenaires sous franchise
ainsi que ses dirigeants directeurs
employés et autres agents représentant
de chacune de ces entités en cas de
plainte d'un tiers relatives aux
dommages
j'ai préjudice qui surviendrait lors de
l'utilisation ou du déploiement des
vaccins sur le territoire de l'état
membre en question un contrat
particulièrement avantageux pour fader
que certains pourrait attribuer à la
situation exceptionnelle nous russell
aurait mis le paquet pour s'assurer un
vaccin efficace et sans danger
sauf que là encore les faits sont
coriaces si le battage médiatique autour
des cas de thrombose liés à la stran eca
a retourné l'opinion contre le sérum
solide au britannique des problèmes
existent aussi pour le kaiser
voici par exemple un tableau comparatif
menée par le gouvernement hongrois est
relayée ici par le compte officiel du
vaccin scouts nick v on y découvre que
le nombre d'infections qui suivent la
vaccination avec du kaiser est le
deuxième total le plus élevé derrière
astrazeneca et pour ceux qui douteraient
de l'objectivité de ce compte twitter
officiel du sérum russe il ya aussi ces
statistiques en provenance d'israël pays
entièrement vacciner avec pfizer et ou
de possibles liens entre la vaccination
et des cas de myocardite chez des hommes
jeunes sont actuellement à l'étude en
guyane aussi deux personnes sont
décédées du coït 19 alors qu'elle avait
pourtant reçu deux doses du vaccin
américano-allemand ses déboires
n'indique pas de manière évidente une
dangerosité du vaccin de pfizer mais
force est de constater que ces cas n'ont
pas été aussi activement relayée dans
les médias que ceux concernant
astrazeneca
le risque étant de laisser planer le
doute sur des vaccins qui pourrait
possiblement être privilégiés plutôt que
d'autres car si on accepte de manière
cynique que le marché de la vaccination
est un marché comme un autre alors les
règles doivent être les mêmes pour tous